merci monsieur cazeneuve la parole est
un monsieur hervé mariton
oui monsieur le premier ministre ou qui
le remplacera nous adhérons aux
objectifs d'un non moins polluer avec
moins de co2 ceux de la lutte contre le
changement climatique dans l'esprit de
la coop 21 l'industrie nucléaire
française
nous dirons donc aux mises de l'économie
peut et doit y contribuer le problème
monsieur le ministre c'est que le
gouvernement des primes
la filière nucléaire française l'action
edf vous l'avez rappelé hier monsieur
ministre a perdu près de 60 % en un an
ce n'est pas qu'en france mais en
allemagne par exemple et on a perdu 30 %
c'est pas la même chose la deutsche bank
a fait une proposition salle engage une
solution pour edf c'est un changement de
majorité
un gouvernement plus ouvert à l'avenir
du nucléaire ce sont évidemment les
français qui décideront
hélas beaucoup d'hypothèques sont
aggravées par le gouvernement fessenheim
sur l'éventuelle fermeture avec mon
collègue socialiste marc goua nous avons
chiffré le coût 4 milliards d'euros
le gouvernement a aussi fragilisé le
dossier d'enfouissement des déchets
nucléaires par le choix d'une mauvaise
procédure parlementaire
le coup est passé de 15 à 30 milliards
d'euros
la procédure n'est évidemment pas en
cause sur ce point mais le coûts
explosent
vous connaissez les difficultés de
recapitalisation d'areva avec un risque
d'aggravation du déficit budgétaire les
enjeux sont considérables l'emploi
l'industrie l'environnement sont en
cause la responsabilité du gouvernement
est grave
alors monsieur le ministre vous
l'accordera quand une loi est mauvaise
il faut la changer gouvernement a
commencé de le faire sur un goy allure
s'agissant du logement
quand le fera t-il sur la loi de
transition énergétique qui sur ce point
massacre la filière nucléaire renoncerez
vous à fermer fessenheim
sinon un jour est ce que vous nous direz
combien cela va coûter combien va coûter
la recapitalisation d'areva
dites nous si vous allez changer de
politique ou préciser nous monsieur
ministre combien de dizaines de
milliards d'euros
votre politique actuelle va encore
coûter aux contribuables ont saisi la
parole est à monsieur emmanuel ma
la ministre de l'économie de l'industrie
et du numérique président monsieur le
député hervé mariton
on pourrait longuement gloser sur les
performance relative des différents
groupes énergéticien français mais
gloser pardon merci de me reprendre
mais je tiens à vous dire que si on
prend le comparable allemand il est bien
pire et honey mw ont été dans des
situations de scission de groupe et
courra cours ils se sont effondrées
durant les deux dernières années nous
n'avons rien à envier aux voisins pour
ce qui est de la situation française
je ne reviendrai pas ici dans la réponse
que je vais vous faire sur les
engagements pris par le gouvernement
dans le cadre de la loi pour la
transition énergétique mais vous avez
raison mais vous avez raison de dire
plus largement que les défis qui sont
aujourd'hui posée au groupe edf sont
nombreux il porte les investissements de
la filière nucléaire
qu attendent en particulier les autres
acteurs sous traitant de rang 1 et de
rang 2 ils portent l'entretien et les
services du parc les marchés à
l'international mais aussi le
financement la transition énergétique
par un fonds qui a été décidé et des
investissements propres qui sont
demandés au groupe est donc face à cette
situation l'état actionnaire à d'abord
pris ses responsabilités en accès en
acceptant que le dividende soit versée
en titres et donc en demandant pas
d'argent comme c'était classiquement le
cas à l'entreprise c'est un premier pas
la deuxième chose c'est que nous sommes
en train de réorganiser la filière
nucléaire
avec comme vous savez une discussion qui
est en train de se finaliser
entre edf et areva et dans ce cadre là
je ne souscris pas à vos propos puisque
ce n'est pas mauvais pour edf
cette réorganisation elle permettra à
edf de contrôler une filiale commune qui
permet justement de produire et
d'exporter des réacteurs et d'avoir
clarifié l'ingénérie de ce groupe donc
c'est bon maintenant le défi qui nous
est porté c'est en effet d'avoir dans
les prochains mois une analyse pleine et
complète du coût complet toutes ces
politiques pour que edf puisse préparer
aussi la transformation de son modèle
parce que l'edf de demain ne sera pas
non plus le modem de l'edf d'hier
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
un monsieur